the interesting you mentioned in my
extensive research
um you used to do 1200 to 1400 an hour
and then you said that you're thinking
of jumping back in at a rate of 2400
the first hour yeah and I think 900 each
successful hour that's interesting
that's like that's that I mean to me
that's really interesting like the for
like why it's like a first hour yeah oh
it's just because uh it depends on how
you want to incentivize like the amount
of hours so if you have to pay up for
the first hour but not pretty much for
the success if you're more likely to buy
like a longer period of time and usually
I find that clients who buy a longer
period of time are nicer to you I don't
have like a great theory for why that is
but there's more likely like taking
dinner and get to know you first and I
just enjoy that a lot more I enjoy like
like knowing who I'm gonna have sex with
like a date you know yeah so it
incentivize the the long form date
Dynamic versus like uh not that's really
interesting
that's really interesting how does money
change the dynamic just basic human
Dynamic of interacting for free versus
for money like I think about that a lot
because like just talking to rich people
it's like you usually get paid for your
time and you're doing this for free
like what uh
like what's the difference is there a
difference really or no a bit Yeah so
I've actually it depends a lot so when I
was doing it full time it was my only
source of income uh that it changed
quite a lot because I was really
incentivized to have repeat customers so
I'm like okay if I'm my primary
interaction with you is to like have you
hire me again I will do whatever that
takes to make that happen and so if I
have to like laugh at jokes that I don't
find funny or like be like more adoring
of your penis than I actually genuinely
feel like that's what I'm going to
express yeah um and obviously it's to
some degree like titrated you know like
I it's unpleasant to force yourself to
like something that you don't so like I
would actually like not see clients
again that I didn't want to but it's
just some degree there was a sort of
self-suppression going on which I think
is this the way it works in any sort of
customer service job like you want the
customer to leave happy so you just make
sure that you are happy the whole time
and you're like ah really enjoying the
other person but uh so recently when
I've like kind of dabbled in it since
baking money for through other means
um where I don't need the money it's
more like a fun wide thing that like
that I'm like I said it's fulfilling the
role of casual sex for me so like I
don't have to do it this is not my
primary job I just want sort of a good
excuse to like have sex with somebody
um and the money is like a great filter
for that uh and so in that case that's
interesting so the money is just but
yeah okay the money is basically a
filter for somebody who's taking this
interaction seriously yeah it also so
there's an interesting like
psychological thing where I have
difficulty having casual sex with
somebody because some part of my brain
which I assume is like quite female is
doing some evaluation of status and
whether or not this is going to damage
my reputation by having sex with them so
like if you found out that I went and
like had random sex with like a homeless
man you might be like wow that says
something about Ayla like maybe she's
you know trashy or she just has no
standards for who she's gonna [__] but
if and so some part of me is continually
anxious I'm like does this mean I have
no standards if I decide to have casual
sex with you like what are people going
to think uh and so if you introduce
money it takes away that anxiety I don't
have to worry about it because it's like
oh of course Ayla would have sex with
that person they paid her like this is
not an indication of the kind of mate
that she can get this is just an
indication of like a business
transaction and this allows me to enjoy
casual sex so much more when somebody
pays me for it to the degree that like I
almost view it as a kink and so it's
like so I'm using it sort of to replace
casual sex now like occasionally you
know like it's pay me a little bit to
erase the anxiety and I'll like have a
fun fun time in case you see like dinner
like that or something like that if a
person pays for dinner or like it's like
it's all just if any money's involved if
it's a kink then you could just like use
it and you you buy it buys a coffee at a
Starbucks it's like all right right but
it has to be plausible like you have to
like trick my brain into like having it
actually be incentivizing for me
like China or something yeah like oh the
homeless man bought me a coffee and then
I sucked this dick like that's not cool
all right so no no shade of homeless man
by the way like I've been friends with a
lot of them I'm just using like some
sort of stereotype of yeah right now so
like it has to be plausible where you
could trick your mind interesting yeah I
mean yeah
so now now with in this sort of frame I
am still like I'm accepting money but
still much more expressive of my actual
preferences so like before when I would
start escorting full time I was
suppressive and now I'm like you know
like I'm doing this for me so we're
going to make sure that I have a good
time and so I'm much more demanding and
then you're having more fun because
you're not pretending exactly laughing
at a joke or something like that that
sounds terrible
sounds like I mean it's also like social
I mean I guess I I would
I do that like when you first meet
people like strangers and so on there's
some aspect of like
niceties but like I don't know intimacy
like real intimacy requires like getting
past the nice cities like laughing at
somebody's joke when it's not funny
feels like anti-intimacy yeah but I
laugh at so many jokes automatically if
it's interesting because like I don't
mean to I'm not trying to be fake but
like if I'm in a group of people and
somebody makes a joke and everybody
laughs I laugh even before I'm checking
within myself like do I genuinely enjoy
this joke yeah so it's like I don't know
like the degree that I am sort of just
like a result of social programming in
all cases that like when I'm with a
client back when I was doing it full
time like it doesn't feel significantly
different it just felt like a different
version of myself
yeah that's true yeah to that degree to
the degree you don't feel like you're
going against yeah your your nature yeah
yeah it was very rare that I actually
felt like I was
against my nature
um what about the market of how much to
charge
say 20 2400 like how transparent is that
market is there like a market like how
much can you sell when you're charging
that much yeah no like what what are the
competitors like if this oh yeah like
what do are you distinctly what because
you said it's uh a lot of is a is a bit
more shrouded a mystery I guess a more
confidential like do you have some
transparency to the the market what the
competitors are so a survey of escorts
only like 130 I'm trying to remember and
the median was around like 400 300 I
think an hour oh wow something like that
with a very long tail at the top end if
I'm trying to remember what the I also
asked the amount that I could calculate
the amount they made per month I think
it was like six or seven thousand
dollars a month I need to double check
that one but I charge 50 bucks an hour
you charge 50 bucks an hour you should
raise your rates oh yeah I give a really
shitty hand job
um all right but usually the the rates
are around like if you want a median
escort in a big city it's usually four
days a city so the urban sorry four four
to six hundred I'm in a big city but
like smaller cities you charge the rates
go lower
um
so that's so fascinating what's like the
most you've ever seen somebody charge
uh I I think I am you're like the
but at this point it's because I'm post
work like I can I can just put it in the
same number there's like in like does
the fact that you're sort of
like a sexuality expert like uh
researcher and so on like your mind is
fascinating as well and you're a bit of
a celebrity does that play into it
yeah uh do you feel the celebrity no
like yeah with people yeah absolutely
usually if people are interested in
hanging out with me it's because of that
um
but that's that's different like I think
besides the like the the fun part like
the this is a kink as opposed to this is
a job like with this as a job usually
the high end is closer to two thousand
an hour
like the very high end